breaking news this hour regarding the
new covid variant first seen
in south africa two positive cases have
been identified
in surrey in patients with no links to
the country
well an urgent testing program is now
planned for
the county we can speak to our science
correspondent thomas moore who has the
details
for us so how were these cases
discovered thomas do we know
so it's almost certainly that they were
picked up by chance that uh there is a
regular screening uh sequencing of virus
samples
and that's how they may well have been
identified because they had no
link to south africa no recent travel
history
and that is the concern that there is
community spread now there have been 103
other cases of the south african variant
but they all
had been to south africa or they lived
with people had contact with people who
had so there was a clear
transmission pathway there but they
don't know for sure how these people
acquired it the fact that there is a
community transmission
of this uh more concerning variant of
the virus
is why they are now arranging surge
testing in two
areas of woking that's goldsworth park
and the john's areas of woking
they will be visited by public health
teams who will put
household testing kits these are pr pcr
kits
through the letterbox everybody in the
house will be
asked to do these tests whether that
whether or not they have symptoms
so they got much better idea on how far
this virus
may have spread they also say that
there's possibility that that will be
extended to
uh in uh in the in the coming days
now both these uh towns are not far from
heathrow
10 15 miles or so so it's in a very
small area it may well have a
ultimately a link from somebody who has
been to south africa perhaps aircrew and
so on who
of course live in that area but that is
is not known what they want to do though
is shut down this virus now
it's no more severe it may have some
impact
on the vaccine though there's no clear
evidence that the vaccines themselves
would be completely ineffective
but for example moderna one of the
vaccine manufacturers has already said
that it's testing out
a new vaccine against the variant
because it is concerned about what it
has seen so far